okay everybody so yesterday at around 8
p.m. finally got the site launched till
now I had I think I had a total of 4
hours of live streaming yesterday then
it spent a lot of time I got in it 8
a.m. and I left at 9 p.m. so there's a
pretty epic day of getting the site
ready I hope I don't have to do that
again any time soon and I'm still still
a little bit sick so my voice is not not
exactly normal right now so sorry for
that but I got my Trello board up right
now and
somebody takes in the in the last okay
sorry I was a little confused my
analytics were showing that basically
nothing was happening and nobody was
watching which is weird because I had
people waiting okay um so I got my
Trello board up here just to show you
last night when I left these were all
clear I had nothing in in this ready for
development section I had nothing in
this section so just from the emails
that I got this morning when I got in
these were all filled up and I've
already knocked some of them out I've
done some of that so I got in a little
bit later than normal today it slept in
a little bit so a lot of the changes are
not really like a big deal some of them
were just like a typo here they're
probably the one that was the biggest
deal was there were a couple of links
that were going to the wrong places
that's that's kind of a big deal it
looks like maybe I am like I skipped I
was just copy and pasting links and I
think I skipped like one link and just
kept going and so the last like three in
a row we're off by one so got that one
fix those those important to fix the
other ones I think I push that live with
with some some edits to the text all
this other stuff is not like a huge deal
except for this part so I have these in
the in progress and this is what I want
to try to accomplish at least most of
this today I'm not going to put in a
full day today because I put in so much
extra time this week so I'll probably
have a short stream today and then get
out a little bit early all right they
hate everybody in the latch head okay
now we've got now it's saying 45 years
that's
that's up closer to what what we
normally have I think I have had over
100 concurrent viewers at once before
but I usually hover like around 50 I
think so I've been working on resizing
images so I want to show you some some
stuff some crazy stuff of having
adventures with image resizing so I'm
going to pull this over and it's going
to be hard to see so let me let me try
to zoom in hopeless there we go
let's try to zoom this as much as I
possibly can
two guys can see when I do the zoom like
this I can't see the lab chat or
anything else so I won't be able to see
anything while we're why I'm assuming
like this okay so this is that big image
on the homepage and I'll read this all
out in case you can't see it because
it's kind of small is 2.1 megabytes of
an image on the homepage just by
converting it from a ping to a jpg we've
got that down to a hundred and eighty
four kilobytes so that's that's pretty
good conversion not that I haven't even
compressed this and I haven't even
attempted to resize it I'm a little bit
nervous to resize this because I worked
on the positioning so much I don't want
to mess it up but for now
that's a big improvement and it's going
to be an even bigger one once I compress
it also I have I haven't even bigger one
here so on on the page for the court or
for the events this was a pain 2.9
megabytes
I think that's crazy like I have whole
sites like the home page on a site that
the entire page is less than that so
that's crazy so just by changing this
into a JPEG I got it down to 598
kilobytes and that's uncompressed so
that's pretty awesome the other one that
was a weird
format really surprising to me was this
so this is a jiff and I don't know why
this was in jiff format that's just it's
weird to me why would I don't know why
you'd use a jiff unless you wanted it to
be him and animated maybe I'm just
missing something but it was it was only
170 kilobytes not nearly as bad as these
other ones so I expected that it would
actually go down in size when I
converted it to JPEG but it didn't it
actually went up that was really
surprising so then I went ahead and
optimized it and I got it down to 104
so from 170 to 104 that's a decent
decrease there but that was just kind of
weird so good to know a jiff that's just
a static image not animated gif is you
know when you're talking about
uncompressed it actually ends up being
smaller than a JPEG so that's all I'm
also resizing some some things so I left
I didn't delete the the original
versions yet because I wanted to show
you this image is on the home page but a
huge it is 3840 pixels wide okay so and
that's it's actually not that it's only
270 kilobytes so compared to these up
these some of these other ones we were
loading it's not as nearly as bad but
that is just a huge huge image so so we
resize that to 700 and look at that I
haven't even compressed it yet again 14
kilobytes so much better I'll show you
where that was on the on the site let me
bring this over so that gigantic picture
was just this at no point does this
image ever get wider than 700 pixels
when we had it at over 3000 so the
images that I had on the site were
embarrassingly large and normally I
would never put images that large on a
site but when I got them
was so rushed I just whatever images I
got I didn't I didn't even look at the
size I just threw him on the site just
to get him on there not something to
look at and then when it came down to it
yesterday just ran out of time and
didn't get to compress him so today I'm
compressing them so sorry to anybody who
tried to view this using your data plan
on your phone I probably cost you you
know a dollar or something trying to
load this page all right let me check
the live chat real quick since I get the
view back to normal alright so has can
you just speak out my name please okay
I'll try my best to say your name this
is its site psych at day I'm not sure
let me know if I did it right on the
pronunciation I really do try to
pronounce the everybody's names properly
everybody always pronounces my name
wrong so I'm definitely aware of that
okay Melissa says what if you need to
preserve transparency they're talking
about the the file formats so um yeah if
you have so normally like a pain can
have transparency and a Jif can have
transparency huh yeah I'm almost
positive a connect transparency but
normally if I wanted transparency I
would just go with the pain I don't know
why that's just like always what what
I've had to work with although it does
kind of seem like maybe that if the gif
has transparency to maybe that would be
a smaller file format I don't know I
have to look into that um some of them I
didn't really need them to be
transparent anymore so I just converted
them into JPEGs because it would be
smaller than a ping
so if they were on like if I could
convert him to a JPEG from a transparent
background and they were going to be on
white anyway and I'd keep the white
background then it would work I don't I
don't need transparency in the same way
there was someone or on a black
background I don't need I didn't need to
keep the transparency for that but
except I probably assumed you're saying
with that this San Damiano jiff that we
just looked at I forgot to check and see
if it converted it to a black background
or a white background some of them were
converting black some were white I don't
know why this one did white I might not
be able to use it if anybody knows I'm
using imagemagick on the command line to
convert these and I'll I'll bring over
my command line in a second and show you
how I'm doing this if anybody knows why
sometimes I'm getting white backgrounds
when I trance when I go from like a
transparent format like a jiff or a ping
to JPEG sometimes it's black sometimes
it's white I don't know why if you know
how I can set that let me know because
that would be helpful when especially
like I need this one to have a black
background it would work and there are
some logos layer that I need to have
white backgrounds but they're gonna be
black so yeah Melissa said you're in a
live chat um Melissa was basically like
answering me Inc and I wasn't looking
cuz I had my screen zoomed in on
everything a few minutes ago and I
couldn't I couldn't see the lot chat so
sam says ping has better compression
okay
how you manage to get all your nails
directly to Trello board alright
somebody asked how I managed to get all
my males directly to Trello board um I'm
not exactly sure what you're saying I am
did I meant it I say someone email said
the mail the emails didn't come directly
and I just basically check my emails and
sorted them out into these so I typed
these out the emails didn't go directly
in there well though that would be cool
if I could grab my emails directly in
the trailer I probably can do that with
zapier just set up a task to check my
email and put it right directly in a
Trello board but alright let's uh let's
do some some Kip right I think out of
all this list probably the thing that's
the most interesting right now the needs
dog is is this image stuff and that's
just because if you're not that good
with photoshop like me then it's a lot
easier to just use the command line to
edit your images so I'm going to show
you how I'm doing out here
I did do a video a while ago on image
compression so if you saw that some of
this is going to be the same but I am
going to show how to resize which I
didn't show that on on that video so
I've got this I just sorted things out
by like subfolders inside my image
folder on my local version of the site
just to keep things organized for me and
then I can see how it looks and moving
into the main folder later on I'll clean
it up and get rid of all these
subfolders before I push this to the
server so basically I'm going through
the home page everything's already good
I still need to get a black background
version of this that's maybe a JPEG this
is not really a huge foam not super
concerned but I want to try to get as
small as I can
so this image was really big and now
it's not smaller let's take a look at
these ones so may I go through expected
I have the files locally but you know
otherwise you can just go into dev tools
and inspect ok see this picture
naturally is it's saying it's let me
blow this up a little bit you can see
it's saying that naturally this is 755
pixels wide but it's only displaying at
371 so that's a little bit wider than we
need on my other screen I'm going to
find this image real quick and move it
to the folder the resize folder oh wow
it's actually even larger than that it's
content here with its 1400 pixels why
that's way bigger than we need alright
so let me let me drop this and the
resize folder and then we will resize it
right on the command line and I might as
well drop these two in as well so these
ones that I've already resized in the
folder I'm going to get rid of then I'm
doing this on my other screen so you
cannot don't worry if you're not seeing
it it's just literally I'm I'm moving
them to the dress okay
okay patrick said he just looked it up
try the the background option so I can
pass a flag as a background and pass it
the color Oh awesome uh let me finish
getting these these images in the right
folder first and then I'm going to try
what what Patrick just suggested thank
you for looking that up it's awesome if
if you've ever seen the image magic
documentation it's like super thorough
but it is it's like trying to just take
a dictionary and start reading it I mean
it's there's so much it's just it's hard
to go through it it's easier to try to
find something on a sac overflow than to
go through that documentation uh okay
fetch Oxfam it old man yeah we
definitely need to resize these images
this one here is over 2000 pixels wide
and then we have one more okay yeah that
that third one also needs resize that's
over thousand pixels okay so let me
let's check out our our folder that
we're doing for conversion so I'm going
to go out hopefully let me know oops let
me know if you can't see this command
line stuff right here if it needs to be
bigger
I'm going to go into this folder I mean
you don't necessarily have to be in the
folder you could do the command and just
go that path but it's easier to see
what's going on like this convert there
we go
okay so we have our original sin Damiano
jiff
okay and that's what we want to have a
black background so we're going to do
convert and
use illicit background let me see
or worse patrick levet background and
have you got past the color we just do a
space and pass it is that I didn't
actually see the documentation we'll try
it like this
this is a copy anyway if I mess it up I
- no big deal um so can I just pass
black do I have to use a hex color we'll
just try it with black for now um and
we'll go the San Damiano a jiff and then
we want to convert that to the JPEG and
we'll just we'll just overwrite that at
length all right let's see what happened
hmm nope all right I'll have to look
that one up but it's good to know now I
know what to look up I'll look up the
background option and see exactly how to
do it Melissa says she's a Photoshop
girl doesn't understand the programming
yet command line is very interesting
yeah that's cool I have there's a guy
that that works with me that is really
awesome with Photoshop but he's on
vacation this week so that's why
normally I wouldn't even be doing all
this stuff I would maybe just run like a
batch compression from the command line
on the whole but all my images but that
would be it and he would handle
everything else so Oh Thank You Melissa
Melissa said the website is beautiful
Thanks the code editor is Adam OSH I
always do that
people ask questions in the live chat
and then they get answered like in the
next line but I don't read ahead before
I answer
Magan asks are there tools automatically
do that yeah basically there are tools
had I've used gulp before and I've set
it up to just use image magic like when
I do my build process it just goes in
and resizes and optimizes on languages
for me it works really well when you
have a lot of images that are going to
be like a standard width and so you know
it's but if you have lots of different
size images is not quite as easy so I
didn't set that up with this project
because I'm using webpack and and I'm
not using gulp I'm not nearly as
knowledgeable about webpack and I'm not
comfortable yet doing stuff like that
probably I need to make like an it just
an NPM script or something to do it but
at this point they're not that many
images so it's not a big deal to just do
it by hand and if you're using a content
management system like WordPress you
upload a file it does all this resizing
for you someone asks is this Python uh
nope um this is well right now I'm on
the command line and then the code over
here is this is CSS and we've got HTML
mixed it with JavaScript here it's a
particular JavaScript framework called
react so that's what we're working with
let's see Oh Jacques Jacques Simon so is
that how you pronounce that Jacques
because sorry if I mispronounced it
Jaques knew decoding he loves free code
camp awesome Sam has a site he can run
images through for compression
okay cool Melissa I did ask you about
the programs I'm using I do have links
to all of them in the in the description
so check out the description this is
Adam this is my text editor I'm using
the seti theme that's seti people are
always interested in a theme and I don't
have that listed this is item two I'm
using for the terminal and then you know
this is just dev tools that comes with
chrome and then my project management
stuff in the background is Trello
alright so let me show you how I'm
resizing these images so I'm going to go
back into the resize folder um and I'll
show you I have those three images that
we were looking at let me let me bring
up the site so we can see it and the
cool part is going to be to compare this
local version to the version that's live
after we do these compressions and we
can actually just see like what the size
of that page is in terms of like
megabytes and though there'll be a
significant difference so I'll help with
load times to the site seems really fast
like faster than it should be because
it's prefetching a lot of stuff in the
background and we're using a
serviceworker
but it's still loading more than I want
it to love it you don't notice it as
much since we set it up like this so I'm
going to go in and we're going to use a
command called log Rifai okay so this is
some image magic - it's just like pretty
much just like using the convert command
except this is when you want to do like
a batch conversion so we're going to do
that and we're going to use the flag
resize and I'm going to pass in well we
need to see what we want how big we want
these to be so basically I'll just check
and I'm just going to spec this and see
how big this is so we have 409 pixels
across and you want to try out because
when we go down lower these are going to
be full width and so I just want to make
sure
this might actually be our largest size
the other one whose what 204 oh and this
one is let's see 537 yeah 537 across I'm
gonna make these 600 I like to go a
little bit over it just gives us some
leeway in case in case I missed
something like I missed a breakpoint or
something where it was bigger I just
round up a little bit so we're gonna go
600 if you just type in one number and
it is come in then it's just the width
and it keeps your aspect ratio and
changes the height in proportion so
that's what we want and the last thing I
need to do is tell it what type of files
I wanted to do this on let me let me
make sure I get this this is right okay
so we're going to use an asterisk and
we're going to say all these are JPEGs
right yep okay so I'm going to bring
over my my files again and I'm going to
do a zoom again and we're going to see
let me bring this oops that's not it is
it
oh shoot I grabbed the wrong image off
to do it um one more time with the zoom
feature on here I'm not great with okay
here we go
this is what I want you city we're at
600 now so all these that were in this
folder are now at 600 I didn't really
want this one in here we'll just delete
that what I really wanted so we'll take
these and we're just going to move them
in here into this folder and I'll say
yeah I want them to replace that and
that's a very replaced
I have backups all these somewhere so
I'm
triple just kind of doing that and then
but we missed an image we missed what
was it the Father Nathan's image but
where was that there was yes oh this
one's still huge yep let's just do a
conversion right there in place on that
alright so we're going to do just the
the one picture version of this 600
we're going to go if we wanted to do it
just on one image father Nathan a JPEG
that's how we do it I'm not going to
change the name I just wanted to convert
that one oops I thought I thought that
was the image name right we just had it
there did I miss something towards that
yeah that's it hmm
it's really weird not sure what's going
on there I'll work on that later
maybe the syntax is different when
you're trying to do one image not sure
about that how much I'm going to check
the logic I'm kind of having like a
relaxed day yesterday was insane so a
little bit more slow paced than normal
live stream someone's eye I mentioned I
use I term and in Naveen says it's only
for Mac with a frowny face
so yeah it's only for Mac I forget
there's something for PC that what do I
use on my PC shoot I can't remember I'm
sorry there's something like I term for
the PC I just can't remember what it is
I haven't worked I have a PC at home
but I haven't worked on it for a long
time I usually just use my my macbook ok
so somebody asked what what did I miss
so far basically we're just going over
image resizing and image conversions and
I'm going to show some image compression
here in a minute and then then I'm going
to kind of wrap it up I'll just you know
go to the live chat and and wrap it up
shooting I totally forgot I wanted to
show another video interview from the
conference I was at last week but I
totally forgot off to remember and do it
on Monday because I want to make sure I
I tagged that person on Twitter when I
when I do the interview
all right so let me just show you how I
do these compressions then let's find an
image that's pretty big so that we can
do a nice and nice compression so which
one was big are the shot okay this
monstrance image is huge is 848
kilobytes so let's compress this thing
so I'm gonna go I keep I keep these
in my google keep and a note there so i
can just copy and paste them real quick
cuz they're way too long for me to
remember so I'm gonna go right in here
and I'm going to copy that now this is
crazy long I'll go through it in just a
second so we're using convert so this is
just the single file version of this
there's a batch version and then there's
a recursive version you can do on
multiple folders which is really cool
for now I'm just going to show this if
you look at my video from a couple weeks
ago on image compression I think I went
through all of them even the the more
advanced ones so we're just going to do
strip that's stripping out all like the
metadata we don't need some of these I'm
going to be honest with you I don't know
what they all do I just I found this
online somewhere and I can't remember
where I wish I could remember because I
would I would you need to give the link
and give credit for this but I've
actually seen this in a couple of places
so I'm not really sure where it
originated from so basically these are
all just various quality 85 this is
about the only one I can understand the
strength in the quality 85 percent I'm
not sure what the other ones do because
I'm not really into you know images and
stuff so these ones at the end this is
the one that you want to convert and
this is what you want it to be named
after you convert it okay so that's it
so let me go here and uh what was that
mmm there we go monstrance this is like
kind of a basic command line thing but
if you don't know all I tagged was Fon
and I knew there were no of there's only
one file when I folder that starts with
mo n so I just hit tab and it
auto-completed the rest for me so that
saves a lot of time typing so if you
only remember one thing from today's
stream remember that and it'll save you
so much time and I just want it to be
called the same thing sometimes I put
like - oh P at the end so I know that I
can trust it but
I just want this to go in mmm actually I
do want to compare it let's put the -
drippy just just so that we can compare
the sizes just for for demonstration
purposes okay so now well before it
would have overwritten that that file
now we'll all right and that's it let's
let's check it out
let's see what see what happened here
okay so we have this one is $2,000 ooh
I'm in a little bit so still big image
mm you know with but 848 kilobytes now
let's check out how we did here there we
go 429 kilobytes so we got that thing
down
almost half almost half way down and
considering where we started so this is
what's on the live site right now this
gigantic thing that's what two point
it's just going off the header two point
one megabytes and now we're down we've
got down to 429 kilobytes so that's what
less than 25% of the size of that that's
huge so that's a huge improvement on
that image it's still a bigger bigger
image that I would like to load but I'm
happy with that that's a pretty big
improvement and we can go back here and
you know let's go back into this page
oops I meant to go to the home page go
back in the home page just to show that
there's no loss of quality I think my
servers again sorry
whoa yuo can appear as a descendant of I
actually got a legit morning that's
weird oh you L cannot appear as a
descendant of P I'll have to change that
we did that yesterday um since we're
last on over it if you guys watched
yesterday I was trying to I just put a
UL again unordered list inside of a P
tag and
I wasn't sure what would happen I just
wanted to see if it would work and
evidently it it's giving me a warning so
maybe I want to fix that it's not like
breaking anything yet is just the
warning but I don't I don't like a later
update to you know break anything so
basically here's that image all
compressed and convert and compressed
these ones the same thing significantly
resize down I'm going to bring in the
this is the live site that has the
uncompressed on resize versions and
we're going to look at them side by side
just to show that there's really like no
noticeable difference in quality alright
let's go up here of in I see you know I
can't tell the difference I don't know
if you all can tell I mean I'll get was
them really close I mean even zoomed in
look at that crazy this image on the
left is less than 25 percent the size
then this image on the right is and they
look identical that's just awesome
so no perceptible loss of quality and
and these ones will be you'll see the
same thing same light zoom in on these
this one you can actually see a bit
let's let me show it it looks look to me
like you can when you zoom in you can
definitely see because of the letters so
you definitely can see it on that one
let's zoom out and see I'm not I worried
about people zooming in but yeah zoomed
out it looks good but yeah you can if
you look really closely you can tell
there's a difference on these images so
they don't look pixelated or anything
but there's a slight change but you know
once again we got a big improvement on
these from resizing these so I mean
maybe I'll look at them again sometime
and see if I need to make them a little
bit larger but I mean these are 700 you
know pixels in width and these boxes are
not nearly 700 pixels so this should be
fine all right I'm going to go I'm going
to check the live chat I'm going to you
know I'm going to wrap this up I'm not
going to go really long today since I
went so long yes turday so let me go to
the live chat I'm going to answer all
your questions now if you don't want to
stick around for the for the questions
that's cool I'll be back
oh maybe not Monday up Monday is a
holiday here in the United States so I
won't be working and I'll probably be at
a picnic at my grandfather's house so
I'll see you on Tuesday and but if you
want to stick around for question answer
go ahead and throw some questions in the
live chat and I'm going to I'm gonna
keep going till I get to the bottom and
unless there's just an insane amount of
questions then I'll have to cut it off
but I'll keep going so I'll get to the
bottom answer the questions as best I
can all right so I'm way I'm kind of
back like halfway up the chat now I
stopped where when Sam was talking about
image compression site where you can
just drag and drop files right on the
site I do use this site sometimes on I
but I have found that that command line
that command on
has been able to get images smaller with
no loss of quality than anything I've
ever used before be it command-line
tools or or Photoshop stuff or even
those websites where you can drag and
drop so this this has just blown me away
in terms of the quality and the size of
what you get okay all right Patrick
actually did put the command that I
needed in here so Thank You Patrick I'm
not going to try it right now um but I'm
definitely gonna I'm going to copy and
paste this right now and I'm gonna put
it in my and Google keep so that I can
remember it I also I do go back and look
through all these live chats so if I
don't get to your comment like I'll see
it you know or you could just throw it
in the comments in the video or direct
message me on Twitter if if you have any
you know something you want to ask me
I'm totally fine with that
all right so so far not a lot of
questions where I'm going I'm looking
you all were kind of talking to each
other always somebody from from Ukraine
awesome thanks for watching
all right I'm Barrett I said are you
scoped correctly you didn't see the
folder structure I think that was when I
was we have what I was trying to use
this commands here um yeah I don't know
maybe was I in the wrong folder I
thought I was in the I was in the image
folder
oh well and I did Patrick mentioned I
was I I used Margaret I last time I was
usually convert this time so it's
possible that the syntax is just
different between the two commands and I
messed that up but if you're only going
to do one image then convert works for
one image usually I think somebody so
hunter it said there's um
Cmdr for Windows that's the program that
I use on Windows and so it's the
equivalent of I term for Mac so for
everybody I was asking about that
earlier it's CMD er that's that's the
name of program for Windows so check
that one out definitely better than the
default
um command line for Windows
melissa says the smaller images will
load faster that that's yeah the smaller
images will definitely load faster it
makes a big difference especially if
you're on like a mobile connection I try
to test all my sites and on a 3G like I
just throttled the network in dev tools
down to 3G so show you here if you go
into dev tools and in network conditions
you can turn it down
so I usually go with 3G and then I'll go
in and refresh the page and just see
like what actually this is the room this
is the wrong dev tools I got my other
one over here on this screen uh maybe to
show you how this I do this
okay so I've set this to 3G i refresh
the page and it will tell me like um how
many requests so you can basically see
like these are all the images that are
requested on your home page and you can
easily see like you know how big they
were or how much time is taking this
like never finishes loading uh because
it's still doing things in the
background so this oh yeah it finally
did be you see there's still there's
like this ton this thing that keeps on
loading over and over again so that's
insane I can't believe it took that one
I do disable the cache when I do this to
simulate somebody coming to site for the
first time any of it usually when I test
sites I that's how I do so I'll compare
I'll do a test like before I change
something and I'll do a test after to
see if I actually had a positive impact
on the site speed
some says homes as soon as you can
change the name though after optimizing
your right I did not change the name
after optimizing that's a good catch
that I can't believe I did that
all right that's why it looked identical
because it was pretty was pretty much
identical
oh all right let's take this to there
okay so yeah so before I hadn't actually
been loading the the new image still
loading the old image so let's compare
now let's zoom that in all right so it's
actually still really good I can't tell
the difference all right so yeah that is
the new one just to whoa we'll just
prove it here just to double-check yep
it is it's the one that says oh P in
there so yeah so that officially not the
last time but this officially is less
than 25% the size of this one on the
right and it looks identical even zoomed
in so once again that's awesome and it's
actually legit this time so good cats
you caught that again that was Hamza all
right so uh or Hamza I'm not sure how to
pronounce that uh so make Hamza thank
you for that catch um someone asked
Jesse gulp or grunt I used to use grunt
a few years
ago but I switched to go gulps gulp
seemed to me easier to configure like
the configuration for gulp is just like
writing JavaScript it's it's more
familiar also it seems faster so that's
why I made a switch I think if you're
like really used to grunt I don't see
any reason like if you're happy with it
I would say maybe I mean I'm I'm not
like an expert at this but I would work
on learning web pack they're not exactly
like the same thing because web pack
does other stuff but check out web pack
if you want to do like react and things
like that if you're just regular
websites I would try to learn how to do
everything you're doing in grunt but
using just regular scripts like NPM
scripts to do it you can do it all it
simplifies things and I've been trying
to learn how to do it as well that's why
my advice if you don't know gulp yet
I don't worry about using it just go
Chinese NPM scripts and web pack Melissa
says a sub question about which command
line tool to use in Windows ok and
i'veeen said yeah that CMD or or skid so
yeah that's that's the one that that I
use Velandia just joined in from Brazil
working as a software developer in the
UK in London so awesome thanks for
watching
he kind of joined in here at the at the
end we did some image resizing a
compression conversion straight from the
command line today I've got some good
results this video will be available the
recording will be available like right
after I am the stream
bill asks what do you use for hosting
the WordPress that you utilize and
calling the API I'm hosting it on a
droplet on digital ocean right now you
don't have to do it like that
if you have like a shared hosting
provider you can still use the API
straight from there it's built into
WordPress now so um yeah any any place
that lets you host WordPress as long as
they don't lock down your plugins like
like there there is some WordPress
specific hosts I can't remember that
there's one in particular worked with it
you there are only certain plugins you
could add so I wouldn't go with
something like that because you want the
freedom to customize um but most of your
shared hosting will allow you to you
know you can do WordPress or you can set
it up on digitalocean I'm actually
running it on a five-dollar droplet
because since I'm only using the API I
don't really need anything more powerful
I'm going to do a lot of caching and I
actually haven't even turned on the
caching yet on the WordPress side of
things and the site's still like pretty
decently fast I'm going to turn it on
after we get most of the content in a
world boss as are you full stack I would
not call myself a full stack developer I
do some things that that would be
considered full stack when I have to
what I would say at least 80% of what I
do is is clearly front-end stuff
occasionally I do stuff that would be
considered DevOps um like setting up you
know servers and stuff and build
processes and things like that that's
just because I don't have anybody I'm
the only front-end developer at the
whole University right now so there's
not really there's another guy in my
department that's he's really good with
stuff um so he can help out uh but it's
not like technically his job to do
things like that so basically I got to
do whatever I have to do to to make the
site's work but I would I wouldn't put
it on my resume
as a front and I that wouldn't be honest
to me to do to say I was full stack I
would but I'm confident saying front end
which preprocessor do I use so Carol
says is asking this whoops preprocessor
um for my CSS I used sass
so I write in sass and then trans
converted over I was editing just some
straight CSS towards the end of this
project I just didn't I was really close
to launching and I didn't have the
automatic conversion set up on the react
site I had it on like the previous
version of this site was just static and
so I didn't have time to go through and
set that up but I do like sass I'll
probably switch up it there's some new
stuff coming up with CSS though so when
that starts to get supported I'm I may
or may not continue to use sass closely
humza okay so earlier I mispronounced
Hamas's name it's I said Hamza that's
not correct it's Hamza so thanks thanks
for telling me how it's how it's
actually pronounced I really do want to
know and pronounce your names correctly
hunter says that they agree that config
for gulp is better and it's also faster
because it uses noted streams okay so
that seems like it more knowledgeable
answer than the one I gave even um he
says in particular it's using note
streams so it's faster actually yeah
you're definitely right I had forgotten
that part of it so correct me if I'm
wrong but this was my understanding
whenever I switched is that um grunt
would step through all your processes
like one at a time but gulp has the
ability to do like multiple things at
once so that's how it can do it so much
faster so I've it's been a couple years
since I've
actually even read anything about that
but I think that was that was the reason
hums I asked planning to do a stream on
the caching part yeah maybe oh um I
didn't show any of the WordPress side of
things so if there's interest in that
maybe I'll do that maybe I'll show like
how I set up I did a plug-in like a
custom plugin in PHP to set up custom
post types maybe I'll show that and then
show the plug-in I actually using a
plug-in for caching so maybe I'll do a
little bit of that as well if you all
want to see that all right Melissa said
thanks for taking time out of the day
you're welcome Lissa this is awesome and
it's not just I don't see this as like
me helping you out so much as us like
collaborating because you'll you know
catch my mistakes and give me a lot of
good good feedback and and good ideas so
I think it's a mutually beneficial
relationship here we have going on
YouTube um all right I think we're at
the bottom we only have two more two
more comments here to go through um men
add Aditya alright I'm sorry if I
mispronounced that it's looking like
Aditya asked our react components
responsive by default if not then you
use materialized or just meteors yeah so
a react component is is not anything by
default really it's whatever you want to
make it so these are responsive because
I use materialize Oh materializes at
framework that's responsive and then
also I added my own media queries where
I needed them so there were there were
some spots where I just needed some more
like fine-grained control over the
positioning of things so I added in some
extra media queries on top of what comes
in materialized but that
that's how so so I guess react by itself
doesn't really it doesn't come with any
markup by itself
so whatever markup you give it it'll
just do that so if you give a responsive
markup it will be responsive if not it
will alright last one of the day unless
somebody put something in here in the
next couple of seconds from Val
um es joins show late and asks um how
long have I been coding in Jay s and
JavaScript um okay so I'll give two
answers I first started when I was in
high school with like super basic stuff
and I didn't do anything with it for a
long time so we're talking like early
2000s right so maybe fifteen or sixteen
years ago I didn't do anything with it
for a long time until I was already
probably maybe like five years ago four
or five years ago I got back into doing
websites and things and as I as I kind
of got deeper into it and had to do more
complicated things for my clients I was
freelancing doing like some
subcontracting work I started clients
started asking for things I did not know
how to do and so I had to learn more
JavaScript so probably I would say like
four or five years ago I can't remember
I thought my head somewhere around there
is what I really like made an effort to
learn JavaScript so I'm not like super
advanced at it I don't I don't think I'm
super advanced and I will you know have
this disclaimer I don't I don't mind
giving the disclaimer like this is my
work and this is how I do it I'm not
claiming that this is the best way to do
it this is just a way I do it like this
I have a full-time job but I have
clients on the side and I produce sites
that work
and I get paid for it and I can support
my family with it so is it the best way
probably not I don't really know but it
gets the job done and I'm I'm generally
proud of my work and you know I'm I'm
happy with the results so that was a
super long answer to that question sorry
for that I still feel a little out of it
from from the from the cold that I have
so sorry for rambling oh we get we got
three more comments while I was talking
all right I'll go through like I said
today is a relaxed day I work 13 hours
yesterday so I'll take some time to go
through these um have you used polymer
Giovanni asks how you use polymer have
you thought more I I've never used
polymer on a site I've looked at it and
messed around with it a little bit I'd
like to learn more about it I'm really
intrigued by it but I just never had the
opportunity to use it on a project yet I
don't know if it has anybody else
watching use polymer when you think
about it you don't have to answer now
you can put in the comments if you want
but I would like to know you can message
me on Twitter in general all my social
media stuff is up on my youtube channel
so whatever you guys you are comfortable
communicating with I'm fine with that
I'm not going to get like mad if you you
know try to find me on some other social
media channel all my information is out
there so there's no sense in trying to
hide anything at this point it's already
out there but if you try to phone call
my phone if you get my number I never
answer if it's a number I don't know so
leave a message or else I won't answer
because if my cell phone is actually on
the Internet so it's the same number I
used when I was freelancing at my own
business I hate the data cap couldn't
watch any live FID oh man was there um
Mohammed Ansari stigmata there's a data
cap in fill in it so in India they
should Wow I did not know that
evidently in India or at least that part
of India there's a data cap so it was
hard to watch live videos so wow that
stinks sorry about that I have it we I'm
in the United States and I do have a
data cap but I don't at work so I'm at
work right now that's how I can stream
this for so long in like 1080p and it's
it's decent quality at home I don't
really know if I could stream this this
one at this quality I might hit my data
cap as well all right Val says thanks
for answering and sharing live you're
welcome thanks for watching and America
says you should be proud of your work it
looks really great
Wow that that means a lot that really
means a lot it's really great to be able
to interact with you like I said I'm
really kind of aside from one other
person that's that does some web stuff
with me here and and he's great he's one
of my favorite people but aside from him
there's really nobody else here that I
can talk to you about web stuff so I
really appreciate the opportunity to get
some feedback from some other developers
and and to help each other out and share
share the knowledge so my voice is kind
of go on my throat's hurting a little
bit and I've been streaming through
longer than I wanted to so I think I'm
going to cut this short
thanks so much for watching any
questions you have put them in the
comments or on Twitter then I will see
you Monday no not Mondays holiday I'll
see you Tuesday
ly back Tuesday probably 2 p.m. again on
Tuesday oh I'll put it out on Twitter
sometime on Tuesday when I'm going to
stream next so have a great weekend